misters anybody else in there with you
no my wife is she okay no no we need the
helper but we can't help her unless you
help us you know how this works
okay I have a weapon please don't have a
weapon don't have a weapon please don't
have a weapon I have my phone okay okay
come out to me come out to me come out
to me hey come out to me oh cool oh cool
oh go come see me 116 is coming out oh
come on come see me go ahead um
Uncle Charles
come on man come on out come on
oh go come see me 116 is coming out oh
come see me go ahead um
come on out man come on now come on now
stay right there stay right there
oh fuck off
put your hands down your back on
oh my God
[Applause]
yes
thank you
yeah breathe man breathe
breathe fuck off come see me
please
hey what's your name